[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight abortion has never been popular
in the state of Alabama since 1973 when
a handful of Supreme Court justices
impose the most left-wing abortion
regime in the world by Fiat voters in
Alabama have strongly disagreed with the
ideology of roe v wade last night after
46 years they finally enacted their
views into law lawmakers there voted
overwhelmingly to ban most abortions in
Alabama and by the way just in Alabama
nowhere else a law like this would not
pass in Maryland and their Jersey or
Massachusetts or pick a state it applies
only in a state where a strong majority
agrees with it where a reflects that
community's values
that's called self-government it's how
democracy is supposed to work a ruling
class doesn't care though they no longer
believe in democracy so they did that
somewhere a thousand miles from Brooklyn
in some little town in Alabama there
might be a person who disagrees with
their views on abortion or gun control
or name a topic that idea drives them
completely insane it eats at them it
keeps them up at night it must be
stopped
well CNN is the network for people who
feel this way watch is one of their
anchor solicits advice and how to
subvert the will of Alabama voters my
feeling is that there are things we can
do for people who want to protest
there's not want to play West yeah first
of all we can talk to the men in our
lives and figure out who are the men
that are not supporting this we can
contribute to Planned Parenthood we can
go and and say this this isn't what we
want this really really it is the most
restrictive law yet for abortion why not
do something on a larger scale dr. Peggy
Drexler a pleasure thank you
thank you yeah CNN thinks you should
donate to Planned Parenthood over on the
view Joy Behar who is both the single
unhappiest person in the world
and also an important figure in
democratic politics when even further
than that
and called for eugenics she demanded
that Alabama's lawmakers be sterilized
on the basis of their sex and skin color
get a picture of the panel of men who
did this and Alabama's yeah what are the
G what do they have in common well I
think they were women all white guys not
here they are oh my god maybe it should
make it a law that they should all be
required to get a vasectomy that group
is well behar is a sub genius granted
and she's not elected to anything either
at least for now
Bernie Sanders though is he's a sitting
u.s. senator and this morning he tweeted
this quote abortion is a constitutional
right which was almost as dumb as
anything Joy Behar has ever said
abortion is not a constitutional right
it is not mentioned in the Constitution
it's not even hinted at the legal
reasoning behind it Roe versus Wade is a
joke even pro-choice legal scholars will
admit that if you ask them in private
but in public nobody can say that nobody
can deviate from the party line everyone
must read from the talking points
provided by the abortion clinic
lobbyists from Nair all and so they do
what they did in Alabama what they did
in Georgia is unconstitutional well this
is an outrage and it's nothing short of
an attack on women's basic human rights
and civil rights today where we saw what
happened in Alabama let us all agree
that women's health care is under
[Applause]
so this is the modern Democratic
orthodoxy if you love women you'll
encourage them to kill their own
offspring if you acknowledge that
children are sacred that being a parent
is honorable and necessary and maybe
even more meaningful than a trip to
Ibiza this summer then you sir are an
oppressor you hate women in case you
haven't noticed it's almost a perfect
inversion of common sense and of nature
itself it's grotesque so what's the
thinking behind it
well that actress Alyssa mono explained
I don't think there's a human on the
planet that is not pro-life nobody wants
to get an abortion nobody we are all
pro-life but there are circumstances
that we cannot avoid there's the
mother's health there's just not being
ready you know and what that means
financially and for someone's destiny
this is an economic issue oh it's an
economic issue so thanks for the honesty
Alyssa without Roe versus Wade women
might understand that they have the
right to be mothers rather than just
dutiful worker bees toiling for some
company that doesn't care about them
they made start to understand that they
could put their families first if they
wanted before the interest of
shareholders can't have that might hurt
markets so our corporate tastemakers
push the lie that abortion is liberation
only in faraway remote places like
Alabama do people miss that message and
continue to believe that children are
more important than market caps and
stock prices but everywhere else the
propaganda is working as intended
according to a new report by the CDC
America's fertility rate is the lowest
it has ever been in the history of the
country it's not that Americans don't
want to have children they do according
to Gallup Americans want just as many
kids as they wanted 20 years ago
it's just they can't afford them anymore
our leaders tell us that's fine it's
totally ok it's normal you don't need
children here's a new iPhone will pay
for your abortion work harder stop
complaining don't listen to those people
in Alabama we will make them be quiet
get back to work you're liberated now